Gad Allon, thank you for being on my show.
How are you?
Great. Great to be here.
So, we had a brief discussion just now.
It was phenomenal.
A little bit of static noise.
So, with the nature of the spontaneity
and covid, we're doing this.
Gad, a professor of operations,
information and decisions at UPENN,
director of the M&T program,
take me to the M&T program
and explain to me.
First of all, who is Gad Allon?
Walk me a little bit through your journey.
And then I'd love to understand
why you chose academia.
And you have a very special part
in academia where you have
both legs out in the real world
and both legs in academia.
Your whole work is in the integration
of all of these moving parts.
So, I'd love to talk about that as well.
But let's start with who is Gad
and transition towards the M&T program.
Yeah, absolutely.
And so, first of all, about myself,
originally from Israel.
So, you probably can hear from the accent
and from my name.
I was born there.
I was a self-taught software developer
from a fairly young age.
Worked when I was 16
with a fairly big project
within giant electronics at the time.
Worked with the several Israeli startups
from really in the area
of large scale databases.
And decided I don't want to be
in front of the computer
for the rest of my life.
Little did I know that all of us
are in front of the computer
for the rest of our life.
And I was in the military for a few years.
I was in elite unit as a soldier and officer
then decide that I don't want to do that.
I moved to the US.
Did my PhD at Columbia
in Decision, Risks and Operations.
We're doing game theory
and queuing theory.
And really, throughout my life
it was a combination of basically
everything I said until now.
So, worked with big firm:
Pepsi, John Deere, airlines.
But continuously also made sure
to stay in touch
with the more entrepreneurial world
and to work with the Israeli firms
or an American firms in very early stages.
Started my own firm while I was at Kellogg,
an education technology firm
that was acquired later on.
Continue to this day to invest in firms
and be on advisory boards of different firms
and always think about the next step.
But few years ago, I moved to PENN
to be the director of the M&T program
but I'll tell you more about it in a minute.
But in fact, what academia really allows you
that if you enjoy the ability
to go deep into an area
and then research that,
but at the same time
the ability to take that
and then apply it to firms,
and if you have the ability to move
between these two worlds in a fluid way,
and I think I managed to create
the flexibility to do that,
it's very hard to compete
with that type of a job.
It's like being in a kid in a candy store
because you can continuously pick up
what would be your next project.
At the same time,
you need to have the patience
to see some of these outcomes.
Right. So, I mean,
you were an entrepreneur until now.
And with an acquisition behind you
you worked with all these different firms.
It seems like the work that you're doing
is still very entrepreneurial also
within academia.
Because you're looking at our world,
and we'll talk about
the gig economy later,
but a lot of the insights
that you're bringing up
they're really trying to understand
how do consumers behave
and what type of solutions work
and what types of solutions don't work.
A lot of the same thought process
that entrepreneurs do,
and obviously, you also have the privilege
of impacting thousands of lives
through the different classes
that you teach, but specifically,
through the wonderful M&T program,
which I got to know
through my good friend Jake Goldman,
who is an alumni of that.
So, tell me a little bit about
what this is
and why you're helping run it?
Yeah. So, the M&T program is the oldest
coordinated degree program at Penn.
So, it's a coordinated dual degree that
the kids are getting a degree from Penn
and a degree,
so a degree from Penn Engineering
and from Wharton,
and whatever they want in engineering
and whatever they want at Wharton.
Right.
But ultimately if I want to explain
what M&T is about, I have to,
I mean, academia
so let me recommend a book.
The book is my favorite book
from last year,
called Range by David Epstein.
And he in fact started by comparing
Tiger Woods and Roger Federer.
And so, how is that related.
Well, Tiger Woods, most of us
are familiar with the fact that he
when he was really really young,
two years old already,
his father put him on the golf course
and said, "Play."
And that was the only focus.
When he was at Stanford
that's the only focus.
Only focus was golf.
Yeah.
Now, many parents, in fact,
built their entire educational endeavor
around that method.
He's actually talking about Roger Federer.
And Roger Federer is very different.
Roger Federer, while everybody knows,
of course, he's a good tennis player.
Well, he started tennis pretty late.
He was a skier, he was a soccer player,
he was a musician, a squash,
he was doing many many
many different things.
And in fact, his mother was a tennis coach
and she did not want to teach him golf,
coach him tennis.
Now, the story is that
if the world looked like a golf course
which means that like the Masters,
nothing changes to fears
then doing one thing since you're born
is the right way but different.
The world look more like a tennis game
where things are changing continuously
because there is an opponent
that is moving
and is improving their skills,
what equals a wicked wall then actually
being fluent in multiple skills.
Being able to do multiple things
at the same time is really
what you want to do.
And so, he's talking about
Copernicus and Van Gogh and many others
that actually are fashioned much more
on what Federer did, and in fact,
what M&T does.
Because M&T is really saying
you need to be someone
that can build products so you want people
that are very good engineers,
people that understand design,
but you also need people
that can motivate you and build teams,
can build culture.
And think at the level of an economy
and understand stakeholders.
And you need this kind of
right brain, left brain, IQ, EQ,
whatever you want to call that
to really make impact at scale.
And that's what like,
for M&T, I can talk about more about
because it's really beyond
just the program.
It's an amazing Alumni group.
And so, for example,
for many of our students,
the first job they got was from an alumni.
The first thing [--] was an alumni.
And when they come to campus
you have a really small cohort of students
that are continues to greet you,
but also you have an amazing Alumni group.
Look at the founder of StubHub
and Snapdeal in India,
and the guy that runs TMT for Goldman,
and the guy who run TMT for KKR,
and the guy who started AQR,
all of them are alums and all of them
have amazing access to our students
just willing to come to campus,
give of the office hours,
give students advice,
just an amazing access
that I think, does not exist really
in any other equivalent program.
And you mentioned before
that this is also
one of the most difficult programs
out of Penn
and they work extremely hard.
I can justify from watching Jake work
how hard they work.
But one thing that I was also very taken
was that when he was so kind
to walk me through the campus
and to get to the building
where the M&T cohort
works out of pre-covid times
and hopefully post-covid times.
And it's really it felt like an open space
of a melting pot of ideas with people
that are all passionate
about making change
and about innovating, right?
So, some of them, I'm guessing,
are a little bit more drawn
towards certain areas in engineering,
some of them a little more
towards finances or business.
But what they're sharing
and what you look for also
in the participants is this
yearning passion for making change
and for being leaders.
And it seems to me
that what you're referring to here,
the specialist versus the generalist,
to make impact at scale
and to really change understand
consumer behavior and move the needle,
you need to be more of a generalist, right?
Right, exactly. And so, to some extent,
what you see sometimes
people feel frustrated
by being a generalist.
And in fact, you do need to be
a specialist in something
to be able to make impact,
to have a path for yourself.
But to make impact at scale,
you need to be able to jump
between multiple worlds.
And it creates some frustration initially.
But in the long term,
it's a little bit like being a bilingual.
What I mean being bilingual means that
at least initially,
you're really not that good
in any one language.
And in the beginning
it's very frustrating.
But we all know that bilinguals
are much better
in almost everything they do
than people who have studied
much languages sequentially.
This is what we are talking about here.
Interesting. And obviously at the end
it's not to take that
they're stretching themselves thin
on either subject, I mean,
they're excelling
at both engineering school
and the business school.
It's not that they're giving
50 here, 50 here.
My my guess is that
usually they have pretty good grades
and usually they come up close
to the top of the class.
So, it seems a little bit natural.
But I'd also have to talk about
the workforce.
And you do interesting, fascinating,
remarkable research with the gig economy,
which is an economy
that I got introduced to
back in high school when I was running
a startup called AnyMeal.
And we had to understand
how can we get a lot of things done
and we didn't have the immediate resources
in my neighborhood for people to help.
And without knowing it,
I had friends all over the world
who on-boarded the organization
of the company,
and they were performing tasks
which I just didn't have
the expertise next to me.
So, talk to me a little bit about
what is the gig economy
and how is it changing a little bit
the mindset of what does it mean
to actually work?
Yeah, it's a great question.
So, first of all, we have to understand
the gig economy on the heels
of what it's being built.
And so, the reason,
I almost have to go back
to the introduction of firms.
Firms exist because of the fact that
what we call transaction cost economics.
It's very hard to manage
many subcontractors.
And that's why I want to be there
to [--] within the firm.
What has changed?
Multiple things.
First of all, mobility.
All of us have a device in our hands.
So, I can always find someone.
Second thing is data.
I always have the data and the ability
to understand who is in need
and who has the skill
and I can try to match them.
So what it means that
in the last few years,
and the names that you hear a lot
are of course, Uber and Lyft
and Jordache.
But these are the [--] entry.
The firms that I'm interested in
are firms like UpWork
and 99designs and HourlyNerds.
And then you get to firms that are
really taking whatever McKinsey
and BCG and Bain did and say,
in fact, their slogan was,
for HourlyNerd was,
"Why should you pay for the partners
second vacation [--]?"
We can renew the consulting.
There's a guy that does the work.
He'll bring you
and we'll charge you actually
only a fraction of that.
And so, that's the main thing,
rather than having all of these skills.
So, if I'm a firm
I can get into all of this.
If I'm the person
I need to design a website
I can find that person.
If I'm a person at these design,
and it's not from the demand side,
the supply side,
you have people that their skills
were very unique, too unique to niche.
There is no too niche now.
Why? Because there is someone
that has the need for your skills,
they will find it.
You will find in Facebook.
You will find somewhere.
And so the combination
of demand and supply
created essentially a world of abundance.
There is really no shortage
of people anymore in any specific skills.
What we need to do, however,
we need to build a platforms to help.
The matching process.
Exactly. That's what we see now.
What we call gig economy,
we talk about usually about this firm
that they're doing the matching
between the two.
And just to give you an idea,
we talk about around 2% of the US now
that making their
the majority of the income from the gig.
The majority?
The majority of the income.
We talk about the fact that
around 60 million people
had at least one encounter
where they got their income
from the gig economy.
We are talking about the fact that
it's going to increase
in the next five years, the GDP,
by around 3.5 trillion dollars.
So, we're seeing here that
you have over 30% of the workforce
just in the US who has experienced
receiving compensation for a gig job.
And here, we say gig interchangeably
but this could be that you're
in the ridesharing service
and you're not tied to one firm.
You can go on to multiple firms, right?
And we see that, of course.
Or it can be that you're on a firm
like UpWork or 99designs.
And I have to say, the one thing
that truly excites me is that obviously,
on our side, as perhaps the clients,
we are able to get things done quicker,
more efficiently.
But on the other end,
this two sided marketplace
it excites me that all of a sudden
people all over the world,
not just in the US,
but people have
these new opportunities
that they never had before.
Access to Internet,
whether it's a mobile or computer,
now allows anybody in the Philippines
to become a book editor
or to become an illustrator
for a book written by
a 24 year old in Palo Alto.
So, it's really incredible opportunity.
And it's mind boggling
how fast it's growing.
Right, exactly.
And so, that's exactly what you see.
We see more and more
labor arbitrage on one side,
that's one way to think about it.
Another way is that
people have much more freedom
to actually maintain careers
in an area that in the past
is very hard to maintain, in location that
in the past is very hard to maintain.
That's exactly what we see now.
But you do a very interesting research
on exactly that question
that those decisions
that a lot of these people
are having to make.
One of the things that
I love to talk about is
what motivates people, right?
So, both in terms of what does it mean
to be a gig worker, but then,
what are the different factors
that either contribute or lack thereof
towards their motivation to work?
Yes, that's a great question.
So, first of all, from the outside,
what motivates them is really,
the majority of them, actually in fact,
don't start with that as the job.
They start just a supplement
and then they see it actually offer them
a lot of flexibility, which is really
the main reason most of them are there.
The majority is the fact that
they have flexibility
they never had before.
But now we want to go into the micro.
And ultimately, the interesting thing
about this economy is that
if you think about the current economy,
most of us make decisions
on where to work once a year.
Once in seven year if you're in academia.
Once in every, maybe once you get tenure,
that's your last decision.
People here make decisions,
where, how long and what has to take
minute by minute.
The question we started with was,
Should we start and develop
a whole new labor economy?
Because you hear a lot of debate
on the policy side,
and what preference you optimize.
And so we had to, first of all,
see what are the main assumptions
we need to make,
what are the main ideas we need to see
when we look at how these people
make decisions.
And so, we got data
from a ridesharing firm
on each transaction they had
for a whole year.
Every offer that was made,
every job that was taken,
everything, everything, everything
for a whole year.
And we look really at three factors.
We look at what's the impact of income,
the offer, basically the wage.
It's not really a wage,
but the equivalent of wage.
Right.
If people are rational,
that's the only thing that should matter.
And the first thing we saw is that
actually that matters and matters a lot.
Which really means that
most of these drivers, in this case,
drivers are highly rational.
I'm saying that because you hear a lot
of journalistic approach, let's say that
you need to protect these people
and they're not rational,
they're captured.
And in fact, most of them
are very rational.
Wages go up, they go more.
Wages go down,
they actually drive less.
There was a bit of a noise there.
Can you just go back and re-state
what did you find,
are the drivers rational or not and why?
Why do you think that they are?
Yes. Let me actually, first of all,
outlined the three main factors
we looked at.
We looked at, first of all,
the impact of earnings.
So, whether the higher the wage offer,
because these drivers get an offer,
base on that firm.
And the question was,
everything else being equal,
if the offer has become higher
are they more likely to accept the job
and work longer?
And the answer was yes.
Not surprising.
Surprising for some people, I should say.
Because there are a lot of research
from the 90s on a taxi driver,
where they chose the opposite.
That the more you pay them,
actually, the less they work.
So we shall know.
But the second thing that was interesting,
actually, we look at
how much people earned until now
and we saw that the people,
the more they earned until now,
the less likely they continue to work,
and the fewer hours they work
if they continue to work.
So, again, the more they earn
until now, the less likely
they're going to continue to do.
Do you explain that because
they have a bucket of expectation
in their mind
and they're reaching the top
of that expectation?
Yeah. I mean, that's the main explanation.
The main explanation what we see
is income targeting.
No one has the dream of driving for Uber.
You want to drive for Uber
only to the extent it allows you
to get a certain level and now,
you can go and play with your kids.
But here comes probably
the more interesting result.
The last result was to look at
what's the impact of the hours
they work until now
on the likelihood to continue to work.
And here, we saw a very interesting result
because the more hours they worked
for that specific firm,
the more likely they are to continue
and work for that firm
and the longer hours they continue.
And I should say this is within a driver
so it's not the cross driver,
within the same driver
take multiple days,
a day in which you work longer
up to that point
is more likely to continue
and go to work longer.
And that is surprising.
That's very surprising.
That's the first indication
in the literature of that behavior.
And we call it inertia.
And our explanation for that, by the way,
is that while these drivers are looking
for flexibility,
they also like within that flexibility
they like the ability to maintain
a certain schedule
or a certain level of consistency.
Now, why is it interesting?
I just think primarily because
of the significant implications for policy,
for example, because these drivers are,
we know that with people,
unlike with our many activities
we do in life
where we're the only one
impacting ourselves.
Here, when you put someone on the road
and they want the longer
they'd driven until now
they're going to drive even longer,
now these are posing risk to other people.
And in here what I see is actually
interesting regulation in New York,
but really try to monitor the same drivers
across multiple firms
and trying to understand
how do we protect society from people
where they can actually harm
not only themselves,
which is bad to begin with,
but actually harm society of all.
And of course,
there is a conflict of interest
because a lot of these firms,
they have an incentive to keep
as many drivers on the road
at any given moment.
Because that gives me a better experience
because I have a match
within a minute, right?
I'm curious, do you think
that is a similar behavior
exhibited by gig workers
in other industries?
Or is that primarily a thing
for mobility?
That's a great question.
That's what we're trying to understand now.
But I'll say one thing, however,
from what you said.
I don't think the firm always
would like to keep drivers driving.
I think the firms,
in fact, when I speak with firm,
with people in these firms,
and that's not across the board,
they would like people to be on the road
when there is work and they prefer
that they be home when there is no work.
They believe that they actually pay,
Exactly.
They actually believe they pay in goodwill
if these drivers are going around
looking for jobs and there is no job.
So, predicting behavior is actually
really really  a key for them.
This is fascinating.
What other things,
because the gig workers is something
that's been your recent endeavor, right?
But you've done more research
across the years.
So, what are some other
really interesting questions
that you've been asking yourself
throughout this research that are relevant
to the world of entrepreneurship?
Yeah. So, one area
that I've been dealing with
quite a bit in the last few years
is how people process information.
And let me explain what I mean by that.
We are in an era where
more than any time in history,
we have more information in our hands
and in fact, we see people
potentially know less about the world
than we know in the past.
And so, that's not where we started.
We started, I would say, in a world
where people have more information,
but this information is coming
in a very high speed
and a very very small chance.
When I talk about that
I'm really talking about this.
The fact that information has
the size of the screen,
and within the screen,
we have very little time
to decide what we read
and we move on and now
there is a new flow of information.
So, we look at that situation
and we say in a world like that,
where also the information sources
are more and more unknown.
I mean, I think about the world that
I was born to.
The world I was born to
we had two newspapers,
in the US it was The New York Times
and The Washington Post.
[--].
In Israel we're different.
You had one or two TV channels,
maybe three, now, we don't talk about
The New York Times anymore.
We talk about this [--].
Or is it someone in the army,
each and every source now
is a different source.
If you look at covid,
many of the people
that actually brought covid
into attention were not even
from the main journals.
Many of them were actually site players.
So, the question we are looking at
is a situation where you look at the data
and one of the things we show, in fact,
is that because of the fact that
we have proliferation of sources
that are in themselves
are not very credible,
when I said not credible,
some of them are credible.
I'm not talking about fake news, by the way,
I'm talking about really the fact
that we are trying to assess
the level of information
in the same time
that we're trying to figure out
what is really the truth.
If we do that, what we get
we get to see that it's actually
highly polarized world.
And then why we get
to highly polarized world?
Because when I evaluate information
I want to evaluate from wherever I am.
I would evaluate
given the information I have
and if the information
is already polarized,
it would become even more
and more polarized.
The reason it's interesting for me is that
we live in a world of platforms
and what we can think about
is how do we regulate many of them.
But what we are trying to show, in fact,
is that regulation,
unless you really understand
why we see what we see,
we might actually regulate
the wrong side of innovation.
And that's why I'm worried about them.
I'm worried about that we tend
not to think about the [--].
We tend to not think about
the implications of regulation,
without truly understanding
how people make decisions.
What is the drivers,
what it is about and use sources,
whether whatever it is about.
And so, that's an overarching theme
of what I'm trying to do.
And as you can see, many of that
is really talking about things
that have changed the last few years
with a lot of this impacted
by current changes in technology
and in the way we consume information.
In just a minute,
why Professor, why teach?
Why stand in front of classrooms?
Sometimes dozens,
sometimes hundreds of students.
And talk about these things
that you're researching?
Yeah.
So, that's a great question.
And in fact, I had the faculty
at the Technion,  Avi Mandelbaum, that said
whenever you do anything,
you have to think about
what is your scope of impact.
When you do consulting,
it's five minutes from now.
When you teach executive MBA students,
it's a year from now.
When you teach undergrad,
MBA is five years from now.
it's 25 years from now.
Many of them are it's too early
for them to impact at now.
But by yourself,
if you teach them things that have,
not only about what you teach,
it's also teaching them how to think of--
Impact, MBA five years from now.
But undergraduate, 25 years from now.
Yeah. And then research,
75 years from now, right?
You want to teach people how to think
not only [--].
You want to teach them the way
and in fact, that impact
is very very hard to have any other way.
And so, I enjoyed being in the classroom.
I love being in the classroom.
A many of my students,
I'm still in touch with them.
In fact, almost every week
I speak with two three students,
former students who work very hard
to replicate this experience.
Unbelievable. Gad, before we leave,
I want to thank you again for being
so generous with your time.
And this is just wonderful and insightful.
And I love watching the different lectures
that you have in YouTube.
And I urge anybody
who is remotely interested
in any of these questions
that you're asking yourself,
which I'm sure,
every young entrepreneur is
because the labor force
and decision making and operations
and processing information is,
that's what 2020 is about.
And, of course, moving forward.
But before we leave,
I have to ask you for three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Yeah.
So, I'll say, first of all, integrity.
I believe in integrative thinking.
I try to integrate many things rigourous.
I try to go as deep as I can
to every topic I take and very direct.
My students know
that I'm very direct in everything I say,
both positive and negative.
Michael, great to be here.
I love it.
Gad, thank you very very much.
Toda raba.
This is just wonderful.
Take care.